so we've got the differential equation
the derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to 3 times y and we want to find
the particular solution that gives us Y
being equal to 2 when X is equal to 1 so
I encourage you to pause this video and
see if you can figure this out on your
own all right now let's work through it
together
so some of you might have immediately
said hey this is this is the form of a
differential equation where the solution
is going to be an exponential and you
just got right to it but I'm not going
to go straight to that I'm just going to
I'm going to recognize that this is a
separable differential equation and then
I'm going to solve it that way so when I
say it's separable that means we can
separate all the Y's dys on one side and
all the x's DX's on the other side and
so what I could do is if I divide both
sides of this equation by Y and multiply
both sides by DX I get 1 over Y dy is
equal to 3 DX now on the left and right
hand sides I have these clean things
that I can now integrate that's what
people talk about when they say
separable differential equations now
here on the left if I wanted to write it
in a fairly general form I could write
well the antiderivative of 1 over Y is
going to be the natural log of the
absolute value of y I'm taking the
antiderivative with respect to Y here
now I could add a constant but I'm going
to add a constant on the right hand side
so there's no reason to add two
arbitrary constants on both sides I
could just add one on one side so that
is going to be equal to the
antiderivative here is going to be is
going to be 3x and I'll add the promised
constant plus C right over there and now
let's think about it a little bit well
we can rewrite this in exponential form
we could say we could write that e to
the 3x plus C is equal to the natural
log of Y I could write the natural log
of Y is equal to e to the 3x plus C now
I could rewrite this as equal to e to
the 3x times e to the C now e to the C
is just going to be some other arbitrary
constant which I could still denote by C
they're going to be different values but
where do
trying to just get a sense of what the
structure of this thing looks like so we
could say this is going to be some
constant times e to the 3x so another
way of thinking about it saying the
absolute value of y is equal to this
this isn't a function yet we're trying
to find this function solution to this
differential equation so this would tell
us that either Y is equal to C e to the
3x or Y is equal to negative C II to the
3x
well we've kept it in general terms I
haven't put any we don't know what C is
so what we could do instead is just pick
this one and then we can solve for C
assuming this one right over here and so
we will see if we can if we can meet
these constraints using this and it'll
essentially take the other one into
consideration whether we're going
positive or negative so let's do that
so when y is equal to 2 when y is equal
to du I'm not going to solve for C to
find the particular solution X is equal
to 1 or X when when X is equal to 1 Y is
equal to 2 so I could write it like that
and we get 2 is equal to C times e to
the 3rd power 3 times 1 and so to solve
for C I can just divide both sides by e
to the third and so I could or I can
multiply both sides times e to the
negative 3rd and I could get 2 e to the
negative third power is equal to C and
so let's now substitute it back in and
our particular solution is going to be Y
is equal to C C is 2 e to the negative
third power times e to the 3x now I have
I'm taking the product of two things
with the same base I can add the
exponents so I could say Y is equal to 2
times e to the 3x and then I'll add the
exponents to the 3 X minus 3 and there
you go
this is one way that you could write the
particular solution that meets these
constraints for this separable
differential equation